[Música]
todos nosotros en algún momento de
nuestra vida hemos querido salvar al
mundo es algo instintivo querer mejorar
el lugar donde vivimos dejar un legado
bueno yo quiero salvar a méxico
desde que era niño con la primaria nos
dejaron de tarea investigar y decidir
que seríamos de gratis y fue entonces
que yo decidí que quería ser presidente
de la república
hubo quien se sorprendió y la mayoría se
rió pero yo no veía porque la lógica era
simple amo a mi país siempre lo vi como
un diamante en bruto una mina de oro
pero tenía muchos problemas y conforme
fui creciendo
vi muchas situaciones que lo ponían en
una situación nada favorable
entonces la lógica era mi país está
sufriendo yo amo mi país y el presidente
era el encargado de hacer los cambios y
de mejorar el lugar
la gente le pagaba literalmente para que
mejorara méxico
entonces yo lo veía simple ser
presidente cambiar a méxico
pero conforme fui creciendo me di cuenta
que si el gobierno es el principal
encargado de hacer los cambios en el
país pero somos en realidad los
mexicanos quienes debemos exigir las
reformas los que debemos darnos cuenta
de las injusticias y reclamarlas
somos quienes debemos pelear por lo que
creemos
entonces fue que decidí empezar a ver la
sociedad mexicana dentro de tres
círculos que desde aquí el nombre de la
plática tres círculos de mexico
uno muy grande como lo pueden ver uno
mediano y por último uno en el centro
dentro del círculo más grande
encontramos a todas estas personas que
en realidad no saben qué está pasando en
el país
no tienen ni idea de los problemas que
afrontamos y en realidad no les importa
yo lo veo como un niño en primaria al
cual en realidad no le preocupa el
producto interno bruto o las reformas a
la constitución
pues en realidad no le afecta mucho está
a gusto viviendo pero problemas son los
adultos que se encuentran aquí porque
los hay
estos adultos son personas que cada seis
años votan por el que hace las promesas
más bonitas el que tiene un nombre
agradable o simplemente por el más guapo
entonces dentro de este círculo están
todas las personas que en realidad viven
a gusto
es difícil mantenerse en este círculo
porque porque en la sociedad que vivimos
la información es muy accesible gracias
a la tecnología
pero personas se esfuerzan por
mantenerse dentro de este círculo
e ignorar todas las situaciones que nos
atañen
dentro del segundo círculo tenemos
entonces
las personas que son conscientes de los
problemas del país personas que saben lo
que estamos viviendo pero que son ajenos
a acción en realidad no toman más allá
de lo que les es conveniente
personas que al tener la información y
esta información puede ser objetiva y
que la puedan haber obtenido de pues de
algún medio confiable o que simplemente
la encontraron en wikipedia o alguna
algún periódico amarillista estas
personas con esta información lo que
hacen es que forman una opinión esta
opinión puede ser de nuevo fundamentada
y argumentada o simplemente
intrascendente
esta opinión en estas personas la
comparte
y en la sociedad que vivimos esta
opinión puede llegar a generar un gran
impacto y cambiar mentes y por eso es
peligroso las personas en este segundo
círculo porque tienen poder poder de
cambiar mentes sin embargo aunque están
convencidas de su opinión
no pueden no tomar la acción para verla
una realidad personas que encuentran
excusas para todo personas que
les es ajena a la acción
y que deciden que aunque haya problemas
no vale la pena resolverlos encontramos
frases como votar por el menos peor
todos son unos rateros
prefieren invertir su tiempo y mente en
otras cosas más importantes
y por último tenemos el tercer círculo
dentro de este tercer círculo
encontramos a los activistas a todos los
líderes sociales
personas que han decidido tomar acción
convencidas de que el cambio es posible
y determinadas a verlo una realidad
aquí es donde queremos estar en este
tercer círculo pero no es fácil por tres
razones número uno
tienes que querer estar aquí
en este tercer círculo no cabe
hipocresía no caben acciones falsas uno
debe que querer estar aquí porque está
convencido en lo que cree y en lo que
lucha porque es una lucha y va a
implicar un esfuerzo mayor en ti y no
puedes hacer este esfuerzo no puedes
lograr esta lucha sin estar convencido
de lo que peleas
luego tenemos también que estas personas
en este tercer círculo se vuelven objeto
de críticas sobre no sólo van a tener
que afrontarse con el problema sino que
todas las personas que opinan al
respecto pueden van a criticarlos porque
si les incomoda
van a atacarlos porque en realidad no
están de acuerdo con este cambio
personas que creen saber mejor que tú y
la cosa está a implantarse bien firme y
seguir adelante
y número 3
los problemas los primeros problemas y
obstáculos que te vas a enfrentar están
dentro de ti tú vas a ser el primero al
que te vas a tener confrontar con tus
acciones pasadas tus creencias pasadas
todo lo que había sido hasta el momento
te vas a tener que enfrentar a eso vas a
tener que superar inseguridades miedos
porque esto va involucrar una lucha y la
lucha empieza contigo de ti te van a
desmoralizar allá afuera pero si tú
estás seguro de lo que crees y estás
seguro de ti mismo no te pueden parar
pero como nos movemos hacia el tercer
círculo
permítanme ponerles unos ejemplos
hace ya casi un año el 25 de mayo de
hecho cumplimos un año desde que las
protestas de black life smarter en eeuu
estallaron
y estas protestas fueron para combatir
el racismo sistemático en este país
tomo un gran impacto internacional y en
redes sociales
yo desde mi humilde posición vi como
varios compañeros y amigos empezaron a
compartir contenido apoyando este
movimiento pero me puse a pensar que en
méxico sufrimos de lo mismo es una
discriminación sistematizada de hace
siglos hacia las comunidades indígenas
ahora a lo que voy con esto no es
criticar a esas personas para nada yo en
realidad les aplaudo que apoyen ese
movimiento y no sé si toman alguna otra
acción para apoyar el otro
pero la situación es que es muy fácil
apoyar un movimiento que se encontraba
luchando al otro extremo bueno no tan
lejos pero si muy lejos de en tu
situación
otro ejemplo es que en 2016 cuando
donald trump estaba en campaña se le
caracterizó por una política migratoria
bastante fuerte había un odio
generalizado en méxico y en realidad
estamos indignados porque no lleva a
tratar a los paisanos que llevan al otro
país buscando una mejor vida pero luego
en 2018 llegaron más de 5.000
inmigrantes en una caravana por el sur
del país que fue lo que hicimos bueno el
gobierno desplegó fuerzas de seguridad
se reportaron personas pero eso tiene
que ver más con relaciones
internacionales y presiones de eeuu lo
preocupante de la situación fue nuestra
ideología de posición tomamos porque
nosotros usamos estadísticas similares a
las de donald trump diciendo que venían
de los países con más alta criminalidad
del delta del continente
nos preocupamos porque qué tal si eran
rateros violadores no sabíamos quiénes
eran iban a entrar a nuestro país
y es aquí donde quiero hacer el énfasis
de que fue muy fácil criticar a una
figura publicada de otro país sobre sus
políticas migratorias pero cuando nos
tocó una posición similar nosotros
tomamos una acción una actitud muy
parecida a la de él y muy preocupante
hubo gente que se dio cuenta de esta
hipocresía y que decidió cambiar su
opinión cambio pues en general toda esa
actitud hacia la caravana
y es así como pasamos al tercer círculo
precisamente haciendo una reflexión como
mexicanos tenemos miedo miedo a vernos
hacia nosotros mismos en un espejo ver
los problemas que tenemos porque la
verdad es que quien está a gusto
viviendo no tiene por qué preocuparse
el status quo nos protege
y entonces es así como hemos construido
un sistema en el que los problemas son
desatendidos y el mal avanza y avanza y
los problemas se vuelven más y más
graves
pero nosotros depende de nosotros
y empezar a erradicar el problema y cómo
podemos erradicar el problema pues
dejando de ser parte de él tenemos que
reconocer que hay un problema porque no
podemos atacar uno que no existe
entonces empieza en nosotros y en cada
uno de nosotros el hacer esta
introspección para ver en realidad que
estamos haciendo mal si en realidad
estamos apoyando el problema que se
quiere erradicar o si en realidad no
estamos haciendo mucho más de lo que
podemos hacer
falta mucha acción y eso es verdad
pero en nuestro pensamiento de es donde
empieza y es que si criticamos sin
fundamentos y damos nuestra humilde
opinión pero sin argumentar en realidad
no vale de nada y se vuelve muy
peligroso
porque no tienes que ir a la
manifestación para apoyar el movimiento
y antes de criticar de decir que son
revoltosos que exageran que no son
formas habría de pensar si no estamos
diciéndoles desde una posición
privilegiada habría que analizar si en
realidad no son formas
y es que si atacas a una persona o
apoyas a otra
eres cairo o fifa
atacando a nuestro oponente y excluyendo
al que piensa diferente es como hemos
construido este sistema donde los
problemas siguen y siguen y no son
atendidos no son atacados
si vemos las condiciones en las que se
vivían hace 100 años y las aborrecemos
sólo podemos asumir que estamos viviendo
hoy en día lo que en 100 años se va a
aborrecer
y que lo que las generaciones pasadas
puedan considerar como controversial
para las nuevas solo es sentido común
vivimos en un mundo donde las ideas
vuelan al otro lado del planeta en un
santiamén asegurémonos de que no sean
ideas vacías de que sean argumentos en
realidad de que tengamos una razón de
por qué pensamos eso y que la razón sea
buena
porque es un poder muy peligroso el que
tenemos hoy en día y hay que usarlo con
responsabilidad
hace no mucho
escuché la frase de si quieres ver un
cambio en el mundo
mírate en el espejo y has un cambio
bueno déjenme decirles que no hay un
espejo
solo estás tú
y en ti comienza este cambio
allá afuera y un méxico que nos necesita
que necesita que estemos en el tercer
círculo y no lo vamos a llegar si no
empezamos con nosotros
toda revolución todo cambio ha empezado
con un sentimiento y un pensamiento el
sentimiento de que como vivimos no está
bien podríamos estar mucho mejor y el
pensamiento de que estamos haciendo mal
y que podríamos hacer bien
al final del día
yo todavía quiero ser presidente pero
duermo tranquilo porque sé que no tengo
que ser el que lo gobierne para ver
cambios realidad
porque soy mexicano y creo que nos toca
a nosotros exigible y empezar a reflejar
en nosotros el cambio que queremos ver
afuera
con determinación un sentimiento a la
vez un pensamiento a la vez una acción a
la vez acompáñenme vamos a salvar a
méxico